hello everybody and welcome back to the
channel I have a very packed week this
week so I'm in a rush to get this one
recorded uh but I did a great job
procrastinating by spending the last 45
minutes uh going online grocery shopping
and uh micro optimizing for every single
coupon possible so uh I've wasted a ton
of time there let's go ahead and get
into it today we'll be talking about how
to build a recommendation engine one
thing this video definitely isn't going
to cover are any details about AI or
machine learning specific content want
to learn more about those consider
checking out brilliant did you also
think that a Fang job would be the key
to solving your dating troubles turns
out it's not because once you start
getting on some hinge dates you realize
that the only time you ever talk is
doing your morning standup routine or
bragging about your TC that's where
brilliant comes in brilliant is a
platform that allows you to self-study
various stem topics like math data
science computer science and machine
learning if you're like me you've
probably noticed that Doom scrolling Tik
Tok every day for the last 3 years has
ruined your ability to focus on anything
Brilliance interactive lessons have kept
me focused and allowed me to learn
compared to my current daily habits of
laying in bed and running through my
tissue Supply I found building a daily
streak on brilliant to be far more
rewarding it's also allowed me to work
on my problem solving skills so that I
can easily deduce the answers to the
tough questions in my life like how come
she hasn't texted me back yet I found
that in particular brilliant's new llm
course has been a major enabler for me
to learn about key Topics in modern
artificial intelligence it allows you to
get hands-on experience with real life
language models now instead of boring my
dates with facts about mundane systems
design I can instead impress them with
how to run gradient descent on a
Transformer Network to try everything
that brilliant has to offer for free for
30 days check out brilliant.org Jordan
hasn lifee or click the link in the
description you'll also get 20% off an
annual subscription to premium all right
so I'm hoping this one won't be too long
uh but admittedly there are a decent
amount of slides so we can go ahead and
try to get through them also what do we
think of that ad hey look who's finally
selling out and doing a great job at it
okay here we go so today we are building
a recommendation engine now I'm going to
build this thing like it could be you
know Amazon recommending products
YouTube recommending videos uh Tik Tok
recommending videos I'm probably going
to think of it conceptually myself as
YouTube videos so maybe it'll help you
guys to do the same uh but note that
this type of design in theory could work
for any of those types of services so
here is an example of a recommendation
that I might get for a YouTube feed uh
you can look at the specific videos
obviously they're tailored to my
particular interest and hobbies but
without further Ado let's formalize some
problem
requirements so number one is going to
be that we want to recommend entities so
the reason I'm using the term entity is
because again this is a generalizable
thing an entity If This Were YouTube
would be a video an entity If This Were
Amazon would be a product and another
thing that we want to do is make make
sure that if we are making
recommendations that we're not
recommending entities that a given user
has already seen cool so like I
mentioned examples are YouTube Tik Tok
and
Amazon all right moving on I'm not going
to give any uh capacity estimates here
just yet I'll briefly go over where they
might be relevant in a little bit uh the
reasoning being that again you know the
types of recommendation engines that you
may be building across these services
are extremely different for example on
Tik Tok a user is going to watch quite a
bit more videos than they would on
YouTube because they're all short form
so it's not really fair to make a single
capacity estimate for all of these I'll
make them where they're relevant so what
would a naive solution to a problem like
this be well
basically it would look something like
this we've got some app servers right so
imagine this is YouTube and in an app
server I would basically say I just
watched a video that would go to my user
history table we could throw that over
in Kafka you know get it over in Flink
combine all that data into parquet files
sync it into a dupe and then once per
day run a batch job where we look at all
of the videos we look at all the history
of a user that you know what they've
watched what they've liked what they've
commented on how long they watched it
and then we could spit out a bunch of
recommendations into a user
recommendation
cache and then that way we go ahead and
load it from our recommendation
servers so that's good uh but there are
a few fundamental issues with it right
it means that for starters intraday
videos will not be recommended which is
not going to be feasible as a YouTuber
when I post a video on a Saturday if I
had zero views for the entirety of that
day I would probably cry and stop
posting uh so it's important that you
get intraday videos in there and
additionally if I go through my cash I
don't want to have to wait until
tomorrow in order to get an up-to-date
cache I would like it to refresh very
quickly cool so now I'm going to kind of
outline the overall ideas uh that we
want to keep in mind when we're making a
service like this and the biggest thing
is that we want to keep our read latency
as low as possible so we want to be able
to fetch recommendations for a user as
fast as possible because whatever we do
on the right path right however long it
takes us to actually create these
recommendations at the end of the day
what we really care about is our user
experience and the user experience is
dictated by how quickly they're able to
fetch all of those videos that they want
to watch cool so perhaps this does
involve some amount of caching per user
but at the same time keep in mind that
there's a trade-off here right a lot of
that caching that we may do may actually
be a front-end optimization so if we're
talking about Tik Tok maybe we see oh
you know what we've got five videos left
in the ones that we currently
recommended right about now we should
start pulling in another set of
potentially recommendable videos and
that way you know we've got this already
pulled in so in addition to the caching
itself being fast or right like a cach
of videos being easily accessible what
we also want is that the actual query to
go ahead and fetch recommended entities
should itself be pretty fast right so we
need to be able to repopulate that cash
quickly so I was just mentioning this
Tik Tok example and uh on YouTube in
general there probably is no cash
because you know you're only loading
those when you first load up the page
and if you actually look at how YouTube
works every time you reload that change
uh or reload that page the recommended
videos do actually change up a little
bit so one could assume that you are
probably running the full query of hey
get the recommended videos for this user
on every single page load cool so again
a lot of this could be front-end
optimizations right it's possible that
YouTube does cash all those videos but
then just randomly actually sends a
subset of them to you every time you
load the page hard to say but I'm going
to spend a lot of time focusing on this
part particularly quickly which is
actually running the query uh to find
those recommended entities cool and so
like I said that involves doing as much
work as possible on the right path so
we're going to have to do some caching
elsewhere great so the first concept
that I want to cover is going to to be
embeddings I did mention I'm not going
to talk a lot about machine learning
Concepts in this video but embeddings
are pretty essential to this problem so
we do have to understand them so
basically if I have two videos for
example how do I actually determine the
similarity between them well I can't
really just look at them frame to frame
I suppose I could but that would require
a human going through them so we want to
be able to represent these things with
numbers somehow or more specifically
with vectors so a vector even though I
draw them as arrows on my screen here
are basically just just going to be you
know a point in
space and so an embedding is basically a
vector representation of our entity so
again a vector representation of a video
or an Amazon product or something like
that so for example if we're drawing out
coders as embeddings we can see Jordan
Jeff Dean and Donald nth are very
similar to one another in that Vector
space but techically the Sham is all the
way on the other end of the coordinate
plane cool so the idea here is we take
our video we actually put it through an
embedding model where an embedding model
just has a bunch of weights and using
those we're able to transform our video
into a singular Vector so keep in mind
in reality that Vector is not going to
have two Dimensions we have to code a
lot of information here and so it'll
probably have hundreds or perhaps even
thousands of Dimensions cool so as far
as our actual embedding model goes uh
like we mentioned our problem
requirements here are that you know we
want to be able to incorporate new
videos into user feeds and we want to be
able to uh refresh our user feed as
necessary and so the embedding model
itself doesn't have to be uh changing in
real time we could perhaps update that
offline in batch and then if we did
change our embedding model or we changed
how we represent our embeddings
obviously we would have to change quite
a bit on our back end to account for
that um another thing to note that I'm
just going to say quickly as a caveat is
that services like Tik Tok for example I
believe I was reading a little bit about
them do actually do some real-time
updates of their embedding model because
the features that they care about in
those vectors are changing all the time
that being said that is a concept for a
different video and perhaps not even for
my channel because it's just not really
what I want to focus
on cool so in conclusion we're actually
going to basically generate these
recommendations in two different steps
via a two-step process so we're going to
call those retrieval and ranking so
they're pretty simple for the most part
in retrieval we fetch the last X
entities that I've interacted with so
let's say for YouTube maybe it's the
last 10 videos that I've interacted with
from there we're basically going to take
each of those last 10 videos and we're
going to fetch for each of them uh the
closest 10 videos to them right so the
last why most similar entities and the
way that we're going to do that is using
our embeddings because embeddings are uh
you know numeric and they allow us to
compute similarity between two vectors
the next step is going to be
ranking after we do all of this
retrieval we now have a bunch of
candidate vectors and we have to rank
them to take the top few that are most
relevant for a given user so we can
basically assign a score to all x * y of
these embeddings we can filter out all
of the entities that I've seen before so
if it's YouTube I don't want to see
recommendations for videos I've already
seen and then all we're going to do is
sort them by their score and return to
the user so it's possible that to some
extent they might already be pre-sorted
right for each one of these entities
maybe all of their neighbors are pr-
sorted so you don't have to do a full
sort but we'll talk about that in a
little
bit cool so the first thing that I'm
going to talk about here are our
recommendation servers right when I want
a list of videos that I want to get
recommended I reach out to the
recommendation server so it is going to
be really really nice for us we're going
to get a lot of good data locality
features if we make sure that I am
always sending my recommendation
requests to the same server and there's
a couple reasons for that first off we
can do quite a bit of pre-caching of the
last entities that I've seen so you know
if I know that uh server a is always
going to be handling my recommendation
requests server a can actually preload
every single video that I watch as I
watch it and that way it doesn't
actually have to go to a database and
fetch them every time I ask for new
recommendations cool and uh in addition
to that you know it can keep some
details about what I did while I was
watching them as well whether I liked
whether I commented whether I disliked
how long I was watching details like
those cool and then another thing that
we can do is that we can actually
potentially pre-cache my interactions
with all historic entities right so this
might be a little bit storage intensive
but if a particular server knows that
it's going to be handling all of my
recommendation requests in the future it
could in theory cach every single entity
that I've ever looked at and that way it
can easily Blacklist entities so they
make sure that they don't recommend them
to me again cool so again the way that
we would do this this is something we've
done plenty on this channel before use
consistent in hashing so that way we
know exactly which user ID is mapped to
which recommendation server and by doing
so we can actually preach all of this
information I will discuss the fall
tolerance of this later in this video
but for now this is just in the overview
phase of it all right so let's start
going through our two-step process so
right now what we're first going to talk
about is Step 1A which is getting those
last X entities like I mentioned this is
information that we want to be
pre-caching on our recommendation server
so let's say that this is me Jordan over
here I watch a video so I watch uh some
kinof live stream
highlights that's going to flow into my
entity history database which I can
Shard on you know my user ID so it all
goes to the same partition we then go
ahead and have all of our change data
captures stream into Kafka and from
there our recommendation server can
handle it so once our recommendation
server gets a specific entity
ID it can say o you know would also be
great not only not only do I want to
pre-cache this entity but I also want to
preash the vector for this entity right
the embedding so it can actually go over
to our entity database which can contain
the embeddings for each particular
entity ID right this is just a mapping
of entity
ID to
embedding and it's possible that you
know if certain videos are super popular
that we may constantly have servers
reaching out to the entity database to
get their embedding and so for that
reason I also o have an entity cache
here right if everyone wants to see the
embedding for the new Mr Beast video we
should probably all be hitting that cach
and just use lru something like that
make it fast great so hopefully that
goes to show how all of the information
pertaining to what entities I interact
with flow down into that recommendation
server and get cached now of course
again if each server I do a little bit
of a computation down here because we
want to make sure that we're not caching
too much information per user right so
if each server handles five entities
for 100,000 users where each embedding
for those entities is a vector of 500
floats so that's four bytes per float
this basically means that that
recommendation server only needs to keep
1 gigabyte of data in memory which is
really not that much this thing probably
has hundreds of gigabytes of RAM on
board and so having to store just one
gigabyte uh for this process is great
because it avoids an extra database call
to get uh my last few watched entities
or last few seen entities every single
time that we make request for
recommended
entities cool so that's Step 1 a step 1
b as we mentioned is we take all of
those last entities that I've seen let's
say the last five videos I watched on
YouTube and we want to find all of the
most similar videos on YouTube to those
that I recently watched great so let's
go through a couple of options option
number one is going to be a vector
database now this is a term that I don't
use very often on my channel but I
actually shouldn't have to because if
you've been watching my channel you
should be familiar amiliar with
geolocation indexes at this point and
Vector databases are effectively the
same thing so we basically take our
entire coordinate space as I show over
here we divide it into a bunch of
bounding boxes right so for example this
top left box this is bounding box a this
top right box is bounding box B and then
we take each of those bounding boxes and
divide them into many ones so as you can
see over here we've got a a a b a c a d
and so for a given Vector keep in mind
that we're actually continuing to divide
these things into bounding boxes and a
given vector's ID within our uh Vector
database is actually just going to be
like a very tiny bounding box that it
belongs to and the utility of this is
that when we actually put all of the
names or vector hashes in our uh in our
database and sort them according to the
alpha alphabetical order of those Vector
hashes uh two vectors that are very
close to one another in the coordinate
plane are close to one another on dis
right so keep in mind this Vector over
here is definitely going to start with
ba and this Vector over here is also
going to start with ba they're close to
one another and so they're close to one
another on disk and so by running a
sequential scan from one of those
vectors uh you know both above and below
it we can easily find the closest
vectors to it now keep in mind that the
unique thing about a vector database
compared to something like a geospatial
index is that a vector database
generalizes to n Dimensions as opposed
to just two Dimensions but this
shouldn't be a problem right it's the
same exact concept and uh you know if
you want to think about this in three
dimensions think about like a massive
Cube filled with a bunch of mini cubes
right you split that Cube into uh
basically eight different cubes and then
you split those into eight different
cubes and then you split those into
eight different cubes and so this
generalizes to nend Dimensions
basically and so again the very nice
thing is that you know let's say I have
a given Vector it just takes me
logarithmic time uh to convert it to a
coordinate hash this is all stuff that I
go over more so in the Geo uh spatial
index video and it all prettyy much
applies here as
well so that's cool however there are
some problems with this so Vector
databases are great and they make for
very good generalizable queries however
we should keep in mind that uh this
process of actually finding the closest
vectors for a given Vector is not so
simple right the first thing we have to
do is convert a vector to a
goash which takes logarithmic time
relative to the number of bounding boxes
from there we have to basically you know
read all of the surrounding bounding
boxes of our vectors bounding box in
order to find some of the closest
vectors right and we basically keep
doing this expanding further and further
outwards until we find at least X of
them where X is our threshold of how
many neighbors that we need then we have
to run some sort of Pythagorean distance
or Pythagorean theorem to find the
distance uh between our two vectors or
some cosine distance or something like
that to basically go ahead and you know
figure out which are the closest let's
say 10 vectors and then from there we
actually we have to go ahead and sort
our results so again we're doing a lot
of work here and then finally you know
we have to basically return this all to
the user right so keep in mind that this
query that I'm talking about you know
let's say I have a vector for a new
Jordan has no life video and you want to
find the five most similar entities
because that's how YouTube does it right
we say return the five nearest neighbors
for the video that you Last Watched
every single user who watches that
Jordan has no life video is going to be
running the same query so you don't
actually have to perform this
computation every time you can just cach
it it's identical for every single user
so for a given entity every user will be
interested in the same X candidate
entities and so we can go ahead and cach
it as I
said great so what is this actually
going to look like when we cach things
for example let's say for entity 10 we
know that the closest Vector is going to
be 121 the next closest is 7 uh 73 or
that's the next closest entity not
Vector sorry and the last closest entity
is 67 for entity 16 it goes 3 55 and
96 so when an entity is first created we
can do two things we can add it to our
Vector database because we're going to
use the vector database to compute its
closest neighbors and then from there we
find the closest X vectors in that
Vector database we can sort them so we
basically run the query that I described
in this last slide we sort them and then
we put them in our index add them as an
index entry however there's one thing
that's problematic here right let's say
that we create a new entity 18 and 18 it
turns out is actually very close to
entity 10 closer in fact than entity 67
over here how is it that we're actually
going to go ahead and update our index
we're we're definitely going to update
our Vector database but we also want to
be able to propagate that over to our
index and perhaps it's possible that 18
is not just close to Vector 10 but it's
also close to entity 16 so we have to
remove both of these guys and replace
them with 18 well let's talk about that
next
so upon intersection of a new entity how
can we ensure that it gets cached in the
close neighbor list so let's say we've
got this Vector B over here and we just
created Vector a which as we can see is
pretty close to it over on that
coordinate plane so let's say if we
actually reimplemented our neighbor list
instead of making it a sorted list like
this we actually used a Max Heap right
so the max Heap is saying e has the
farthest
distance from
B what we could do now is then compare
the distance of a to B which would be
this guy here with e to B which is that
guy over there so we can see a is
clearly closer so what do we do we pop E
from our Max Heap we insert a and we let
it bubble down basically or actually I
believe when you're inserting in a heap
you insert it at the bottom and then you
let it bubble up to where it has to go
but uh yeah gist is that's how things
are going to go here so basically our
final State should look something like
this B now has a and C which are really
close to it and the furthest Vector from
it is D hence why D is at the top of
that Heap so one thing to note here is
uh you know if we want to be realistic
about things you can't really keep a Max
Heap on a database right it's not a
structure that uh works very well over
there you probably do have to keep it in
memory and so this can get expensive so
so if you don't want to do it you're
just going to have to incur greater
right penalties by keeping this whole
thing in a database if you can do it by
storing everything in memory it'll make
the right speed of actually inserting
new embeddings into your database quite
a bit
faster next let's talk about
partitioning so we have two things to
partition right we have to partition our
Vector database and we also have to
partition our actual neighbor index that
we create on top of that so our Vector
database is pretty simple to partition
we've spoken about how we would
partition a geospatial index we want to
do the same thing for our Vector
database so basically it's the same
exact idea here we basically want to
take any points that are within the same
bounding box and squash those on the
same partition because when I'm running
a quaran I want to see the nearest
vectors to me it's most useful when all
the vectors that are actually close to
me AKA they're in my same bounding box
are on my partition and what that really
means in reality is that it's basically
just uh range-based partitioning
on the vector
hash cool the next aspect of things is
actually going to be our neighbor index
so the first thing that I want to talk
about is uh partitioning it basically
the same exact way as the vector
database right so that you know if for a
given entity it's very similar to
another entity they're on the same
partition this is going to be useful for
us for when we actually insert new
entities right so if I'm going back over
here let's remind ourselves that you
know we insert Vector a and it's
possible now that that's really really
close to both b and c and d and so now
we want to notice that a is actually
going to be in all of their neighbor
indexes so we have to update multiple
different vectors at once if these guys
are all on different partitions that
could be pretty slow because now we have
to write to multiple different places we
may even have to use a two-phase commit
but if they're on the same partition we
can use a single Atomic right to that
partition
so it definitely does benefit us to have
that however at the same time if that's
how we partition things uh we may run
into problems when actually reading our
neighbor index the reason being we can
have hot partitions let's imagine that
we're thinking about Mr Beast videos
they're obviously super popular because
they're all my Mr Beast they're probably
pretty similar in beddings so because of
the fact that he individually gets so
much traffic that uh particular Shard
that holds all of the Mr Beast videos uh
would probably get tons of load and it
would be very bad so what can we do well
we can use our typical techniques to uh
try and alleviate load AKA adding more
readon replicas or adding more caching
or here's another potential solution
that I've come up with here is that we
can use change data capture to basically
create a second set of readon replicas
of our neighbor index however this time
instead of partitioning that readon
replica in the same way as our right uh
basically our leaders right which are
partitioned by the hash the vector now
we should basically Shard by hash of the
entity ID so this way you know if um I'm
looking at all Mr Beast uh entities they
should all be put on completely
different shards because we're basically
just randomly hashing them out it
doesn't really matter what the video is
we're just going to throw it and try and
distribute them evenly so the way that
we would do that is you know we've got
our neighbor index which is sharded by
the vector hash range on the left over
here and when we write to it we take all
of those changes we throw them over here
into Kafka into the appropriate
partition uh based on the entity ID and
then we sync those into our neighbor
index which is actually going to be
sharded by The Entity hash and this is
what we want the recommendation server
to be reading so that we can avoid
having a bunch of hot partitions we can
also have a cache in between there as
well to speed things up even further
which I do do in the final diagram so
yeah keep in mind that uh another thing
that would be nice is you know rather
than in this index over here keeping
everything as a heap we know that it's
read only so it doesn't really you know
afford us anything to uh keep it as a
Heap what we could actually do is keep
all of those Neighbors in a sorted list
because that way we can just return a
sorted list back to the recommendation
server rather than a heap where you know
sorting the entries in a heap is still
and log
in I digress but uh hopefully you guys
are following along a little bit here
cool so we've gotten through this whole
major piece of how we're going to
basically find all of the closest
neighbors to the last few videos or ENT
that we've looked
at so now we get into step two which is
going to be the ranking phase which is
where we start assigning actual scores
to our embeddings so the idea is we want
to return a bunch of sorted lists of all
of those neighbor vectors which we're
now going to call candidates right and
now we want to go ahead and merge them
together so let's say we have X
different lists the reason being that we
had X different videos that we recently
watched which we're basing this off of
and each of them are length y so that
means there were y Neighbors in the
neighbor index
our merge time of doing all those things
is going to be o of Y log X this is
assuming that we already have the
distance um of each of these vectors to
the actual Vector that we recently
looked at right so for each of these
candidate vectors I know its distance to
uh like the last scene Vector that you
know I've looked at in the first place
and so now we're basically merging a
bunch of sorted
lists like so and this requires
basically taking a heap
of pointers to each of these three uh
sorted lists and then cherry picking one
element at a time and putting it in our
sorted
list uh like so and the gist is that is
the following time complexity this is
another problem we've talked about
plenty on this channel cool so the
question now might become because this
is something that people asked me a lot
about in the prior video what if we
wanted to actually perform some amount
of user specific scoring per entity
right because right now the way things
are built if I watch a Mr Beast video
and you watch a Mr Beast video even if I
thumbs uped it and you thumbs downed it
we wouldn't actually assign any uh
different scores to all of these uh
neighbor embeddings that we got back we
would basically treat them the same way
and I imagine that's probably not ideal
right if I thumbs down a video I
probably don't want to see all of its
very similar videos in my recommended
list so what we could do is keep in mind
that in addition to basically caching
the last few entities that I've
interacted with I can actually cach the
interaction that I did with all of those
entities which for example for YouTube
is basically going to be something like
the watch time of that entity whether or
not I liked it or disliked it and
whether I commented right these are all
pretty good signals in my opinion of you
know whether you want to see more of
these
videos so what you can do is basically
you know say okay for each of these
lists right let's say I watched a Mr
Beast video and now I have 10 neighbors
of that video I disliked the Mr Beast
video so now what I'm going to do is is
apply some sort of scaling factor to all
of the scores that I have where the
scores are just distances to the Mr
Beast video on the neighbors of the Mr
Beast video so maybe because I disliked
it now all the scores go down by a
factor of 10 right so we have some sort
of scaling Factor we apply it to each of
the lists of Y elements and that way we
can actually keep our read time
complexity the same because now we're
still merging a bunch of sorted lists we
just take into account that scaling
Factor on the contrary if you want
wanted to do a more complicated machine
learning inference right where we
actually went through each of those
embeddings and did a customized
operation to score each one of them then
what would happen is we would have to
resort that entire list globally and now
all of a sudden we would have U A Time
complexity of O of XY log XY right
because this is how many candidates we
have we have XY
candidates and then the time complexity
of sorting a list is you know n log n so
in this case it would be XY log XY
cool the next piece that we're going to
be talking about is actually filtering
out seen entities once I have a sorted
candidate list let's say of size 100
maybe I've already seen 10 of those
entities and I don't want them
recommended to me again so how can we
actually do this well keep in mind we do
have some sort of entity history table
right every single time that I watch a
YouTube video we're putting that in some
sort of database and you know we can
ensure that we are able to load these
things relatively fast by sharding it by
our user ID and then basically sorting
that or having an index on our entity ID
so that way I can say oh you know if I
have um entity 10 14 and 15 has Jordan
watched those in the past I can quickly
go to the database and figure that out
so this is pretty good for figuring out
whether I've seen a specific list of
entities that being said it's still a
network call right and we want to avoid
these wherever possible so how can we
avoid this potentially expensive call to
the database well we're going to use
something that we've used plenty of on
this channel as well and that is going
to be the bloom filter what is a bloom
filter Bloom filters are a fixed size
memory
buffer that are comprised of multiple
different hash functions so you can see
I've got four different hash functions
so let's say you know entity a comes in
right and I run a through all four of
those hash functions and it lands a in
these four
buckets let's say entity B comes in and
B
lands in these four
buckets okay now let's go ahead and say
that entity C comes in right so I'm
considering whether or not I should send
entity c as a recommendation to the user
so I take a look at my Bloom filter and
I say okay maybe C hashes to this bucket
C hashes to this bucket oh wait C hashes
to this Bucket over here meaning that we
couldn't have Cen C before because if we
had Cen C before this bucket would not
be empty right you know in reality of
just saying a here we would just have
some tick mark like a you know a
occupied or not occupied and so because
we know that bucket is not occupied it
means that we couldn't have seen C and
so it's good to send it to the user now
we've avoided an extra database call to
figure out whether C was in there
another thing that we can do uh
unfortunately or rather a downside about
the bloom filter is let's say d comes
along right so D hashes to this bucket D
hashes to this bucket D hashes to this
bucket bucket and dhes to this bucket
you might note that we've never seen D
before but just looking at the bloom
filter it seems like we have the point
is if the bloom filter actually says
that we've seen something before we
can't know for sure and we still have to
go to the database if it says that we
haven't seen something before we do know
that for sure actually and we can go
ahead and send that candidate Vector
over to our client because it's valid to
recommend so again fixed size memory
tells us deterministically when we have
not seen an element if it tells us that
we have seen an element we still have to
go to the
database again the nice thing about it
being fixed size is it means that we
don't have to store a ton of data on our
recommendation server right because if
this is Tik Tok and I've watched
literally a million videos which at this
point on Tik Tok I've probably watched
in like the many thousands of videos
because they're so short uh you would
have to store every single one of those
video IDs on your recommendation server
and that's not feasible so by using a
fix size buffer like this we can keep
the memory footprint relatively low
while also eliminating some percentage
of calls that we would have to make to
the
database okay so let's actually continue
to talk about Blom filters in terms of
how we would create them so keep in mind
that all of our recommendation servers
are already listening to the change data
capture of our entity history table the
reason being that for every
recommendation uh the server has to know
my entity history right it has to know
the last five YouTube videos that I've
watched so anything that goes in this
table already has to flow through kovka
and the recommendation server so that we
can cach it up here so in addition to
caching those last you know say five
videos what we can also do is add them
into our Bloom filter right so we're now
going to be handling every single one of
these videos but again the bloom filter
is a fix size buffer and so as a result
of that you know it's not going to
expand beyond our control we can
basically limit it to the size that
works best for us so again if we're not
sure whether we've actually seen the
entity which is going to happen when we
have a false positive in the bloom
filter we're going to have to reach out
to the D datase the entry uh The Entity
history table to confirm that for
us okay now we run into an additional
problem right which is that we're
basically caching a ton of stuff on our
server over here in particular the bloom
filter and also ourselves seeing the
last few videos so how can we make this
fall tolerant because this is all being
stored in memory and if this server gets
hit with a hammer and it goes down well
we're going to lose that state and that
wouldn't be great so as far as our last
few entities that we looked at go this
this is pretty easy to retrieve from our
entity history database right if it's
five entries that's not a hard query I
literally just go right here and read
them we can make this a little bit
faster by using a local secondary Index
right where we take all the time stamps
of when I actually viewed that entity
and we sort them and that way it's very
quick to find the last few right so
we're going to use a secondary index of
view
time however as far as the bloom filter
goes that is going to be a bit more
problematic if we lose it the reason
being that in order to build up that St
of the bloom filter I literally have to
keep track of every single entity that
I've ever looked at and so if this guy
were to go down for me to basically
restore the state of that bloom filter
now all of a sudden I have to do a full
scan of every single thing that I've
ever looked at and so if this is Amazon
products or it's Tik Tok videos that
could literally be in the hundreds of
thousands and that would be very bad
that would be very slow then to bring up
a server after it had come down when
we're trying to restore this state so
what can we do instead well basically
what we really need is a stateful fault
tolerant stream consumer now at this
point your eyes should be glazing over
because you should say Jordan you
[__] [__] this is Flink isn't it
you're close it's not Flink because
Flink is not really meant to be doing uh
HTTP requests which is what we need to
be doing on our recommendation server
however it is effectively going to do
the same exact thing that Flink does
which is every few minutes or every few
seconds what we do is we take this Bloom
filter we throw it in S3 and then we
also say what index of the Kafka log
this corresponded to so maybe this was
S3 at index
172 and so now if this guy goes down and
another recommendation server comes
up it loads the data from S3 and then it
starts reading from offset 172 onwards
in Kafka and that way it can actually
build back up that same exact State
because if we didn't have the bloom
filter right if we had an empty Bloom
filter we would assume that we haven't
actually seen any entities for our user
and if we assume that then we wouldn't
Blacklist any of them and we would just
return them entities that they've
already seen before and then they would
be upset so that would be
bad okay so we finally made it to the
final diagram I think so far everything
I've actually explained okay today which
is in contrast to my normal videos but
of course I will hear from you all in
the comments section so let's go ahead
and go through the different paths
number one we have the entity upload
service so what what would this be this
is for example uploading a new YouTube
video so I have it as the same guy both
getting recommendations and uploading
entities in reality it's probably
different people doing this so you can
see here that I basically actually have
some inmemory
broker the reason being that it may be a
little bit expensive to actually create
the ENT uh the embeddings for all of
these entities which is what we have to
do when we first create them right so if
this is YouTube obviously we've got all
sorts of consumers of this list that are
you know creating different encodings of
the video uh they're publishing it to a
variety of places they're calculating
the thumbnails and different encodings
of that thumbnail but for the sake of
our video I'm just going to draw out
this one consumer that I care about
which is going to be the embedding
Creator right so this is some sort of
model that we have that maybe gets
updated every once in a while but for
now all it's going to do is basically
take our video and convert it to a
vector and from there we have to do a
few different things with that Vector
for starters we have to put it in the
vector database which is sharded on our
Vector hashes as we discussed so that
way you get good data local
to find similar vectors to the one that
we just created from there we now say
okay for the new Vector that I just
created I just found the 10 closest
neighbors let me now look at those 10
closest Neighbors in our actual neighbor
index and see if I have to update those
neighbor indexes to ref uh reflect the
fact that I now have a new Vector so we
can go ahead and do that we would put
that in our neighbor index like so and
then in order to achieve fall Tolerance
on this memory based cache what we do is
we take all the changes that we make we
throw them in Kafka we basically
reshuffle them because they were
previously sharded on vector hashes and
we really want for fast reads and making
sure that we don't have any hot
partitions is to partition these guys on
the entity hash range right so I don't
care about the vector hash um as far as
partitioning I want basically you know
video 10 might be represented as Sorry
video 10 might be represented as a
vector of like 3 47 uh 62 this is the
vector but instead of sharding on this
now I want to Shard on this cool so
we're going to Shard on this guy instead
so that they're evenly distributed
across all entities across this table
over here in addition to updating our
neighbor index as I mentioned so that
this way we can make sure that new
videos are included in recommendations
we also actually want to put uh the
mapping from 10 to its particular Vector
into the entity database over here we
can just index these by The Entity ID
and them accordingly uh the reasoning
being that for a given entity ID I would
like to be able to very quickly find its
embedding and so we need an index to do
that great we have all of that so we've
got our neighbor Index right that we
care about basically um you know being
able to quickly figure out all the
neighbors for a given video that I've
watched uh we've got some cash because
you know let's say for Mr Beast videos
tons of people are going to be getting
that in their recommendations and so
videos like those should be hitting uh
this neighbor index cache and then of
course the next step of this process is
actually going to be interacting with
entities right a new video gets posted I
watch it so what types of things go in
here maybe
likes
comments watch
time and that's all basically going to
flow through our ENT entity history
database so this is keeping track of all
the user interactions with the videos or
the Amazon products or anything like
that that they interact with on our
service again we want to Shard those by
user ID so that it's very easy to load
for a given user uh we want to index
these by entity ID so we can quickly
tell for a given entity whether I've
interacted it uh interacted with it or
not and again it would also be nice to
have a secondary index on the timestamp
of all of those interactions so I can
very quickly figure out what the last
few interactions that I performed
actually were so that we can formulate
recommendations based off of
those again in typical Jordan fashion
we're going to have these flow all
through change data cap and into Kafka
and then we're going to cash them on our
recommendation service the reason for
this being the recommendation service is
saying hey for user 55 the last entities
that they watched were 12 13 and 62
right these are the last three entities
that we watched so now when user 55 over
here goes and asks for some
recommendations this recommendation
service is going to say ooh hey for 12
13 and 62 go get me the closest uhti to
that it's actually going to reach out
into the neighbor index cache which uh
if it's not populated will reach back to
the neighbor index it's going to figure
out all of those closest entities and
then now on here on this recommendation
service we're going to perform
sorting which again we're going to use
basically a heap and all of these sorted
lists merge them together and then
return them right back to the
user note that this really only works
all of this pre-computation and all of
this preaching if we're sure that
deterministically a given recommendation
server is going to be handling all of
these requests for a given user and the
way that we do that is by basically
charting all of them on the hash of the
user ID so we're vertically scaling out
via load balancer or sorry not
vertically scaling we're horizontally
sharting or horizontally scaling out
this recommendation service based on the
hash of our user ID and we're going to
use consistent hashing to do that
somewhere over here we would probably
have some zookeeper blah blah blah so
another thing to note or to remember is
that the recommendation service is also
holding our Bloom
filters and we don't want to lose those
Bloom filters we need these guys because
it's going to help us avoid extra calls
over here to our entity history database
so as long as we have this Bloom filter
it's a pretty nice optimization but it's
very easy for this guy to go down and
lose the bloom filter so that's why
every few seconds we go ahead and
checkpoint our state of the bloom filter
over here in S3 as well as our Kafka
offset and that way if we have to bring
up another node and basically have it
restore the state of this previous
recommendation server we can relatively
quickly do that by reading from S3
reading from the corresponding offset in
Kafka and then quickly going to our
entity history database and getting the
last three videos that that person has
watched now all of a sudden we have
restored all of our state well guys I
hope this makes sense and I hope it was
a good one again sorry about the ads uh
I'll see how the feedback is on it but I
tried to make it somewhat entertaining
and and uh yeah I'll see you guys in the
next one